just to give you a sense of this right
I'm 24 years old I'm the youngest person
in the company I'm the newest hire in
the company and six months later I got
named CEO Prodigy that's pretty good
pretty good right and the way to do that
is you
[Music]
actually welcome to a new segment that
we're calling it's like a Q&A but we're
not calling it a Q&A we're calling it
questionable advice
does that mean that someone shouldn't
follow the advice or that we're just
answering questions and giving advice it
it means whatever people needed to me
and it's people asking questions us
giving ADV advice the advice is a little
bit questionable as well right because
we're not telling you what necessarily
you should do we're saying what we what
we've done that works for us it may or
may not work for you it may may not be
the best way it's just the only way we
know and so today the question we want
to answer is actually different than
usual normally we're always talking
about starting companies starting
businesses being a CEO being an owner
being an investor but today it's about
what happens if you're not there yet
what happens if you're inside of a big
company so how do you stand out inside
of a big Co how do you become a
superstar employee how do you become an
employee that is just god tier and that
opens up a whole bunch of doors for you
inside of a company how many employees
have you had like that every company
there's always one or two there's always
one or two that are just like so clear
and what I did was I basically plucked
what are the things that they do like
what what are the things I remember that
they did that stood out to me as well as
a couple things I did after we got
Acquired and we went to Twitch what are
some things that I tried that actually I
felt worked um because you know I had to
spend two years inside of a bigger
company for the first time in my life
and I experimented I tried a whole bunch
of things I'm not going to talk about
the ones that failed because those were
embarrassing or not useful but I will
share the ones that that worked dude
what's crazy is let me add two things
back stories to our our perspective on
this one you had someone who worked at
um monkey Inferno and all the other
companies that monkey infro started well
you actually had a few interesting
people the first interesting person was
Steve Bartlett who's famous for his
agency and his uh podcast Diary of a CEO
I think the second person who's even
more interesting is Faron a guy who
started a company that's worth tens of
billions of dollars I was shocked that
that guy would be would would consider
you a coworker that was a that was an
amazing get the second point I want to
add to this person and you probably you
actually had a few other people that
were you know Jason Hitchcock you had a
few other people that are wildly
successful um the second thing to add to
this one of the best compliments I've
received from you in the last probably
60 days is you texted me and you said
how on Earth did you get Steph trong and
I forget who else you named how on Earth
did you brainwash them into working for
you for as long as they did and that so
we've had we we've each had a handful of
super super stars who I don't ever use
the word work for me because often time
it doesn't I I hate that it's not that
it's we work together on something and
I'm only going to be able to have them
for a little a short amount of time
that's principle number one you work
with you don't work for and it's
actually a pretty big mentality shift
which is working with somebody is a
partnership it's an agreement it's a
mutually beneficial Thing versus I work
for you is a you know um you know
there's a dominant person and there's a
person who's just basically takes orders
and does whatever's you know whatever
they have to do you know based on the
the task list and you never want to be
the work for the work for is you know
you a servant essentially whereas
working with is a partnership but it's
okay to have to be that for for a little
while actually for someone who's
interesting like if if like Shawn Pur
doesn't have a a specific need to get
done and some kid is like dude I will
I'm competent I will do exactly what you
say for a little while it's okay to do
that for a little while but I agree in
general you don't want to be that person
but but yeah yeah working with is is how
I consider it to be done correctly I
hired a chief assf just now uh this kid
basically had a job at I think like JP
Morgan and he was like hey uh he just
emailed me emailed me emailed me saying
he wants to do stuff um he's like I can
help you with this I can help you with
this is there a reason you're not doing
this and uh then I'd be like no not
really I should do it he's like how
about I come do it for you I was like I
don't know about you you whatever he's
like here's an example here I'm doing it
blah blah blah and finally he did it and
I was like cool you're going to quit
your job he's like I guess can go quit
right now like if you say I'm in I'll go
quit and I said okay Bet and then he
went and talked to his boss and he quit
his job Banking and now he's my chief of
staff and even for him on day one I told
him this I said we work with each other
and not you don't work for me because I
actually want somebody who's gonna treat
themselves that way because they're
gonna get they're actually gonna get way
more done they're going to be more
productive they're gonna be a higher
caliber person if they think that way
it's a mindset shift did you actually
say bet dude it's 22 I got to speak the
language all right everyone a quick
break to tell you about HubSpot and this
one's easy because I'm going to show you
an example of how I'm doing this at my
company when I say I I mean not my team
I mean I'm the one who actually made
this so I've got this company called
Hampton you can check it out join
hampton.com it's a community for
Founders and one of the ways that we've
grown is we've created these surveys
where we'll ask our members certain
questions that a lot of people a lot of
times people are afraid to ask so things
like what their net worth is how their
assets are allocated all these like
interesting questions and then we'll put
it in a survey and I went and made a
landing p so you can check it out at
join hampton.com wealth you can actually
see the landing page that I made and the
hard part with this is with Hampton we
are appealing to a sort of a a
higher-end customer sort of like like a
Louis Vuitton or Ferrari so I needed the
landing page to look a very particular
way HubSpot has templates that's what we
use we just Chang the colors a little
bit to match our brand very easy they
have this drag and drop version of their
Landing Page Builder and it's super
simple I'm not Technical and I'm the one
who actually made it and once it's made
I then shared it on social media and we
had thousands of people see it and
thousands of people who gave us their
information and I can then see over the
next handful of weeks this is how much
revenue came in from this wealth survey
that I did this is where the revenue
came from so it came from Twitter it
came from LinkedIn whatever it came from
I can actually go and look at it and I
can say oh well that worked that didn't
work do more of that do less of that and
if you're interested in making landing
pages like this I highly suggest it look
I'm actually doing it but you can check
it out go to the link in the description
of YouTube and get started all right now
back to f m the first subcategory or the
first category I think we should have we
both have things that involve
communication and writing do you want to
like name a few that you have under that
category yeah okay so I'll do I'll do
one simple one so write an internal
newsletter people know us as the
newsletter guys because you created the
hustle read by millions of people I
created milk road which became the
biggest crypto newsletter
the the newsletter thing isn't just for
external um so you know you can have
100,000 subscribers a newsletter but I
if you're inside of a company what you
really want is 20 subscribers but
they're the 20 most interesting people
in the company and so what I did when I
got to Twitch was there was a um a team
like Bezos has something called the s
team I don't know if you this Amazon's
like his like 15 to 20 top lieutenants
and twitch being owned by Amazon had its
version of this called te team and so I
got put on t team and so you know te
team is like whatever 15 of the top
people in the company and I go to the
first meeting and you know it's it's a
busy meeting they're not you know
they're like oh hey welcome Sean we we
just acquired the Sean want to say hi
I'm like I say hi for two seconds but
really I don't know any of these people
and so what I did was I created a
newsletter and I created it for all of
the T team and then I would slowly
anytime i' meet somebody interesting
anywhere in the company I'd be like oh
by the way I write this thing every week
and only goes out to you know a select
number of people um it's it's fun you'll
like it I'm G to add you I'm gonna add
you to the list and so they're like okay
cool I'll be added whatever
um and what I would do is I copied uh
James clear's newsletter format James
CLE does something called one 123 um
guess what I wrote the 321 newsletter
internally which was basically like you
know um it was uh or no sorry he does
321 I did one two three so I did one
photo from my camera roll so here's a
photo I did two thoughts which is just
like two like kind of tweet length
things that I'm thinking about inside
the company and three links which is
just random that I've seen what
type of
photos uh it would be usually something
like um you know not work rated so for
example culture building thing like I
saw John brought in this funny mug not
not work related at all it would just be
something about my life that's in like
an interesting thing for my life and I'm
not a big Instagram guy but I kind of
get the idea which is a photo can say a
lot about you and what you're interested
in and all it could kind of brag a
little bit like okay my kid learned how
to ride a bike this weekend yeah exactly
such a good dad you know like here's
what I'm doing and so you know like for
example I did one photo that was this
list that my um my niece had made she's
seven and she she wrote her like routine
she's like Ellie's day and then it was
um Eat Play Sleep eat play play sleep
and I was like somehow the
seven-year-olds got it figured out what
are the rest of us doing and right like
that's the life you got to live and so
people loved it they were like oh yeah
that's so true blah blah blah and so
would just one photo two thoughts Three
Links I would send that out every Sunday
and I wrote I said hey the way I framed
it I go you know when I was a startup
founder I used to send this to my uh our
investors and board of advisers every
Sunday I'd write like an update on kind
of where my heads at well you know old
old habits die hard even though I'm not
a startup founder anymore I'm working at
twitch um I still have this hour every
Sunday I'd like to you guys are now my
new my new board of advisers you guys
are my new you know mentors at this
company so I wanted to include you on
this if you're on this list it's because
I think you're one of the more
interesting people in the company that I
hope to to learn from and get to know
over time and so that was how I started
it and I wrote that thing dude I can't
tell you how much juice I got out of
this right because it took me about 45
minutes to write this every Sunday but
now I'm getting sort of like you know
every single person's attention in a
very and they they know about me they
learn about me they have an opinion
about me not everybody loved it I'm sure
I'm sure some people were like whatever
I don't care about this but it didn't
matter it got like forwarded up there
was a guy who was like the the VP at
Amazon Prime would email me like dude I
love these Sunday things man he's like I
wish we got to work together because he
he wasn't even in the company it got
forwarded to him and he was like dude
these are awesome you want to like just
meet this you sound great you sound
awesome and that's the whole goal you
want to build a brand internally and one
easy hack to do this is the internal
newsletter and there's actually uh I
think even more implications of this so
one of the greatest people I worked with
was Steph Smith she's been on the Pod
many times she's already doing great
things and is going to go on to do even
bigger things she uh there's this thing
with history I read a lot of history
where often times the person who writes
the most popular history book or who
writes history books they actually
control the they control what we think
of History even if it's fake she did
that of course in a good way where it
was very tactical she actually could she
was the best Google Sheets maker and a
really good Google Slides maker and so
she would dictate how the Google sheet
for the projects that she ran and then
eventually other projects how they
looked and that actually dictated what
we tracked which d
things that we do yeah and but she would
make these I don't know did I ever tell
you the sheet that we had for Trends did
I ever show you that no I I'll just show
it to you sometime but she made this
beautiful sheet it autofilled and like I
was like oh thanks for doing this this
is amazing you should do this for all
these other things but she basically
controlled the information flow and so
if anyone had a question if anyone
wanted to know anything they had to go
to her and she wasn't doing this for bad
reasons but be she was basically a very
powerful person because of that reason
and so you need to get really good at
presenting your work and you need to be
really really loud about it but you have
to be great at presenting your work
making presentations writing stuff
controlling the Google Sheets and making
them look presentable and making them
work well that is incredibly important
and not not enough people think about
that 100% 100% the winners right history
right and and uh and also the other
thing is you want to be a maker not a
taker so most people in companies are
just takers of plans so somebody else
writes the plan somebody else makes the
doc somebody else creates the dashboard
and you just sit on the receiving end of
it what I would do you know when I was
at these companies is I would always
write my own versions of the plans and
this was partly for practice because I
wanted to if I want to be the CEO well
then I should get reps doing the things
that the CEO is doing he's writing an
annual plan cool I'm GNA write one too
what would I say and you write it and
then you compare to what they wrote and
you see things that they did better and
you see some things that maybe they
missed out on and so being a plan writer
being a proposal writer being a uh
update writer is going to be the thing
that actually sharpens your skill so
that you if you want to be a leader what
most people think is I'll wait till I'm
promoted and then I'll start doing
leader things that's not really how it
works right you start doing leader
things and then you get recognized and
promoted and so if you want to one day
be the leader you got to be the plan
maker not the plan Taker and you you
want to write your own version of all
the things that all the key key stuff
the annual plan the quarterly update the
um the launch guide whatever whatever it
is for a given project the next thing I
would say is and this is actually
challenging for a lot of people I have a
feeling it wasn't challenging for you
because you're a very competent person
but it's important to be a to to be loud
and when I say loud I don't mean that
you have to talk a lot but I just mean
you have to make sure everyone knows the
cool that you're doing and there's
a fine line between being selfish and
stealing other people's stuff and taking
too much credit and then also being loud
but it's important to be loud to let
everyone know these are all the amazing
things that are happening and you have
to present that in a really wonderful
way where it shows progress and it shows
even if you screwed stuff up here's the
swings we took I think I always had this
problem I I noticed it particularly
amongst the women who worked for me I
would always have to encourage them I'd
be like dude you got to speak up you got
to be louder about this this is
really awesome you are not inserting
yourself into the conversations nearly
enough that you should this is really
really talented amazing work so I think
being loud is incredibly important to
sticking out within a company yeah
exactly you want to work in public so
you want to you know present the things
that you're doing and like you said it's
not all bragging so for example you know
people would would would report in a
format that's sort of like here's the
here's what went well here's what didn't
do well here's the screw-ups that we had
this week and some of the things we
learned from that are what we're going
to do to fix it so like it doesn't have
to just be everything I did was great
and I'm the best and I did everything
you know it was all me me me me it's not
that however you're totally right that
you're really only rewarded for for what
people know about if you're if what
you're doing can't be measured or isn't
seen it might as well have not existed
inside of a big company and for a lot of
people that's very uncomfortable to do
they wish the world worked differently
where it was just purely purely Merit
based and everything was equally visible
it's just not true like if a tree falls
in the forest and there's no one there
right like you know you need to be able
to to highlight what you're up to and uh
you know carve out 10% of your time to
doing that let me tell you one more
thing that's uh a bit unrelated but very
controversial and it took me hard it
took me a long time and I had to go
through a lot of tough challenges to
learn this titles matter did you I
imagine when you started your early
companies and maybe you still do this
now you like dude I don't care about
titles you can call yourself anything
you want it it means nothing to me this
is a flat organization but titles
actually matter for an employee and they
matter because of the job that you have
there but also the job that you can get
elsewhere so give me an example because
I would disagree with this I don't think
they matter that much what's what's the
example you're thinking of where it
mattered okay so if you want to be
called the head of something um that's
actually really important for the
employee it's actually scary for the
employer because you want to say you you
if you give someone the head of
marketing you can't hire someone above
them or if you do there's going to cause
tension however for the employee if they
go and work at a new company they're
going to now say look I was already head
of marketing at this company I need to
be CMO or I need to have something of
equal seniority additionally within the
business if you if it's the head of
blank I'm the head of marketing
everything that go happens within that I
need to have my say or I need to have my
finger on the pulse with that um titles
I actually think are a really important
thing they seem not important to an
entrepreneur because you say these
things like oh it doesn't matter we're
all working together but I actually
think they're I they matter for the
employee so I would say in my opinion
the logos matter so there's a funny
thing that happens where it's like you I
bet you're guilty of this too let's say
you're uh you're building um Hampton now
it's like a community or membership
based
product if you see oh this person ran
Community or memberships at whatever YPO
YPO Soho house whatever no known known
Thing versus unknown brand for some
reason we just sort of attribute all of
the success of that company to like this
person must be a winner because that
company's a winner even if they had very
little to do with the winning of that
company that the secondary Step At The
Hustle I had a guy who worked at
Facebook and he wanted to join us and I
was like oh you're in and we hired him
and he was it was horrible but I totally
fell victim to that I've done that all I
do that all the time this happens to me
with live streaming people are like oh
you worked at twitch oh we we need
somebody we're doing live streaming so
it'd be amazing to have you on board
because of your experience at twitch
they don't know my experience at twitch
they don't know what the hell I was
doing there I learned way more about
live streaming at my startup that they
don't know about that was actually
building live streaming that was working
in that space But if all I had was that
unknown startup name I would have gotten
zero credit for being like know live
streaming expert guy and so I think
logos matter a lot and just getting a
win a winner logo unfortunately that
stamp that stamp is is cool um the thing
no different than having Harvard or an
Ivy League an ivy oh if you're good
enough to pass that bar you're good
enough and and one is enough one is
enough that's the key I think one
problem people get into is they go logo
collecting one is enough if you if you
got Harvard awesome you don't need to
also go get you know another NBA from
some other place or if you have Facebook
you don't have to make the next one
Google you can make the next one a
little higher varant variance because
the Facebook will carry the other thing
I'd say is managers matter so when we
got acquired by twitch we were getting
interviewed by people and we got
interviewed by several people when we
were joining and they were like they
were supposed to be diling the
acquisition but I was also dilc in them
because I was like dude I know that
managers matter people don't quit jobs
they quit managers and also if you're
stuck under a manager who doesn't have a
lot of respect in the org you're not
even going to get to see a lot of the
interesting that goes on or even if
you do stuff it's going to be buried
under however much clout that manager
has and so they first tried to put me
under somebody and I was like no no no
no I'm not working for that guy and
they're like what what's what's the
problem I was I was like nice guy I'm
not working for him and they were like I
was like is there anybody else cuz uh
you know maybe these two people I liked
them they see because they clearly like
you know were buds with the CEO and had
more more like they were doing all the
interesting projects and this guy's over
here working on trust and safety or
maintenance of something or like you
know Plumbing under the under the bridge
like I'm not trying to work on all those
boring those boring projects or
with that guy that guy has no respect in
in the org and I think managers matter
pick somebody you're going to learn a
lot from but also somebody who got who
has some surface area that you can get
done and switch if you if you if
you don't like where you're at try to
actively switch um all right I have a
different one wait hold on dude when I
sold to the when I sold the hustle to
HubSpot it was uh the the the plan early
on was I'm out of the picture and I'm
just going to do the Pod but they were
like all right how about like VP of
marketing and you report to this guy and
I was like yeah can we give me like a
lower title and you can make Brad who's
my VP make him the VP and I'll report to
him and it it was just like way better
but I was like yeah let's let's breing
it down and not I'm not gonna be a VP
all right now there's something I call
the five perent rule I learned this from
foran so when we got acquired by twitch
we're sitting there and we were supposed
to work on X right we were we were at
that time a taker we got acquired to do
this let's do this and uh FR wasn't very
motivated and I was like dude come on
let's try to do a good job here right
like we don't have to totally sandbag
this I get it it's not like the same as
when it was our company and this might
become the next big thing but like you
seem totally checked out and he was like
no no no I'm I'm not checked out with
the company he's like but look at this
they pulled up the overall company
dashboard he goes best case scenario
this thing that we're building best case
scenario which of these metrics
changes and I'm looking at the key the
number one dashboard for the company the
the key kpis overall ones I was like
well none of these go to page three
there's subdivision subdivision and then
this one and he's like cool so let's say
all right let's say we change that one
how much do you think that changes the
overall picture like he's like don't you
think that we should at least like if we
do a great job what we should do should
make at least a 5% impact in the
company and I was like my ego gets
involved I'm like yeah of course 5%
that's SS low actually he's like yeah
he's like I just think we're capable of
doing something that's going to at least
move the needle 5% he's like he's like I
feel like if I did something and it
didn't even whatever we did if we did a
good job if we if we succeeded but it
couldn't even move the needle 5% he's
like I kind of feel like that was like a
waste of time and that's what I learned
this 5 per Rule and we we immediately
switched to something that would do that
and it was such a good decision I
wouldn't have done this but in the same
way that nval says you want to place a
absurd hourly rate on your time so that
you value your time and you put a price
tag on your time this actually is also
inside of a company you need to put a
price tag on your projects that you
simply will not work on projects that
can't move the needle for the ACT for
the company because if not why am I here
what is the point and if you carry
yourself with somebody who can actually
move the deal for the company it's sort
of self-fulfilling you will become that
person who actually can do that simply
like you just raised your standard and
now that's what you do dude you you you
were lucky to have fon course Fon I
don't know if he was he the co-founder
or was he one of the first hires at App
11 so app 11's a a adtech company $5
billion market cap at 130 billion market
cap amazing guy so he joined the company
before he was even App 11 he was not one
of the co-founders he was just like a
random engineer that they hired they had
like eight people he was like person
nine within a couple months they were
like all right this guy's the guy right
he stood out like a superstar does this
guy's the guy let and they went to him
they're like hey I think we kind of
built this team wrong now that we see
you and we look at the other eight
people we hired before you that are
above you like we realize we did this
backwards can you like fire all these
people and rehire a new team of people
like you he's like okay so he did that
he ends up getting like a you know
co-founder Equity stake in the thing you
know becomes It Go ends up going public
it's like a 20 billion dollar company
you know years later same thing happens
I hire him at at Monkey Inferno as
Android engineer only right so there's
like you know above him there's director
of engineering above him is the CTO
above him is me within a couple months I
was like oh this guy is a superstar like
I you know Android engineer is simply
the wrong title and I told him I said
look uh you're GNA end up in a different
role just give me a month to figure this
out and within a month we had switched
it up where he ended up becoming CTO and
we basically rebuilt the whole team
around him he sort of has like a master
sensei like a like a that type of wisdom
to him where for some reason whenever he
says something I believe him and I and I
think he is actually right a lot more
importantly all the engineers you'll
ever hire will believe them right this
guy's a leader of Engineers which is
like extremely valuable um let me give
you another another principle all right
here's a simple one fix your Zoom
setup just don't look like dog on
every call in fact you should look
incredible on every call it doesn't cost
that much to do it like you could do it
with an iPhone app there's an iPhone app
called camo you can download that's what
I'm recording on right now by the way
and you could be DSLR quality from your
from your iPhone if that's all you have
if you want to get one better just get a
light right like a light off Amazon
that's 50 bucks and that app will set
you in the top 1% of people at work of
in terms of how you look when you show
up do that and have also buy a
podcasting mic uh your mic can be you
know a Yeti a Blue Yeti microphone if
you need even better would be these like
sure microphones you just just look good
and sound good because like no matter
how good your ideas are if it's wrapped
up in a crap sand sandwich it's going to
just come across poorly and um it's the
you know is the digital equivalent of
dressing good and uh I think people
really underestimate this I think you
make this like a rule at your company
right I I try to make it a rule and I'll
give it I'll get really tactical I'm
using a sh M I'm traveling right now
this is my travel kit a sure mv7 USB mic
that's $200 an iPhone with a $50 camo
subscription and $150 Elgato key light
that's that's my setup when I travel so
if you think looks good enough that's
what it is yeah it's going to be better
than most people's like up the nose shot
with the crappy audio and like you know
sitting in a closet somewhere so so try
try on that well furcon actually is a
great example of this and a few other
people really did a good job at this I
think that when you get into a group
whether it's work or any other type of
group oftentimes the most confident
person is not usually the smartest
person but the most confident person
wins and I think confidence is displayed
in a way of saying things like this is
uh this is the path we're going to go
down this is what we're going to do I
have a 60% chance certainty that this is
actually going to work my logic is this
this and this but this is this is the
answer at least this is the answer for
us to try and I think that at a company
when you work with a small company like
any company I've run you work with the
CEO or the owner um at a larger company
you know it'll it'll it'll go up to the
owner somehow or the CEO but it still
matters with managers and BPS and
like that but the confident person that
says this is the way and they dictate
the way and they explain their reasoning
and they're confident about it and you
start believing in them you still have
to be right more than you're wrong but
the most confident people I think
typically succeed the most I agree I'll
give you two things one the thing you
just described is like U I think it's
called the McKenzie pyramid principle
are you aware of this no so
basically most people get communication
wrong inside of a company
because they bury the lead so what
they'll normally do is they'll say
beginning middle end like a story and in
the end is the conclusion the end is the
takeaway what we should do it's what's
what what we decided whatever but busy
people inside companies which are most
of the leaders inside companies they
don't like that format they want the
opposite they what they want is to say
my recommendation is we should do
this for these three reasons number one
number two and number three and I
believe those three reasons because we
have evidence underneath this this we do
not have evidence for but we will but
it's a reversible decision and this
third thing blah blah blah right you
stack the the main conclusion first and
then you you like a pyramid underneath
you support it with your supporting
arguments and that's just a simple
communication thing to flip another
communication thing to flip that I
learned was um there's if you want to
become a more clear Communicator use the
what why so what framework EMT from
twitch taught me this so basically it's
what happened or what's going to happen
so you know if it's past looking what
happened it's if it's forward looking
what we're going to do why it happened
why we why we're going to do it and the
last one is so what so you know let's
just give an
example um what happened is the the
metrics let's say uh you know revenue is
down 10% this month why because last
month we did this extra promotion so we
kind of knew it would artificially
inflate last month's Revenue this month
is actually normal if look at the
overall trend line um nothing to worry
about here so what um so we're going to
continue doing this and actually we're
going to consider doing those extra
promotions every other month because
they seem to Prov provide a boost or
whatever all right like you just you get
the idea what why so what just is a
generically useful template or outline
like you can write that on your paper
before you figure out what are you going
to say in this email or how you going to
write this document just write what why
so what and you should be able to bullet
point under that and then that's 80 to
90% of the material is already done at
that point and I find what helps is if
you put a confidence level in there
because a lot of times people think well
if you're confident you're saying that
there's a 99 or 100% chance that
whatever is gonna you're say is going to
happen is going to happen you shouldn't
do that you should say I'm actually you
should be really conservative and say
like you know 65% 70% like I'm I'm
fairly certain or sometimes you're like
I'm actually I actually think there's a
30% chance that this works but if it
does work the outside returns are quite
huge and if it doesn't work it's
reversible in these ways and so I think
you need like a little bit of a uh uh I
don't know how you would say it like a
an easy Landing if you fail Superstars
do three things number one they think in
probabilities not certainties that's
what you just described the second thing
is that they manage expectations which
is the second thing you just said which
is you don't need to overpromise and
underd deliver in fact you know under
promise and overd deliver is a better
mindset and uh I remember one time going
into a meeting and uh this is something
I learned from my dad we were going to a
big partnership pitch meeting and we
thought we thought they have this thing
and with our technology they're going to
get this huge yield this huge result and
the result is like a hundred times
better than their current thing so I was
like oh slam dunk put that on the slide
baby 100 times better and we go into the
meeting and I my dad puts up the slide
and I notice that he's changed it and it
only says three times better and I'm
like dude you messed up like what
happened why' you do that and he's like
he's like did you see their faces about
three times better they were over the
moon that other stuff is now my dry
powder like I can beat if I could beat
the three times even better if I said a
100 times and we came in at 80 times
better it would be seen as we did not
deliver on what we promised he's like
and so you know what whatever forever
you know forget the exact you know
numbers here the the principle holds
true which is only sell to the amount
you need to sell that like gets them to
agree to Greenlight the thing or take
action but don't over promp beyond that
even if you think it's capable because
you'd always rather beat your numbers uh
beating your numbers is is like you know
how you exceed expectations and it makes
you trust them more and so here's an
example so and I'm looking at the deck
now so Google uh whoever's listening you
guys can Google Uber uh C deck so in
2008 Uber was just getting started
they're raising only
$200,000 and on slide 20 they have a
deck or a slide that says potential
outcomes and they say best case scenario
becomes a market leader with over a
billion dollars in annual revenue
realistic scenario gets 5% of the top
cities and we make around 20 or $30
million a year in profit worst case we
stay a 10ar 100 Client Services business
and just saves some time for San
Francisco base Executives versus when
you see a slide deck from a pitch and it
like everything is like up to the right
you're like right dude I don't trust you
now because you are saying something
outlandish like this and you're saying
it with a huge High degree of certainty
right so uh yeah anyway the confidence
thing on the confidence thing is people
think confidence comes from answers no
confidence comes through asking
intelligent questions um any leader
knows that you could tell a person's
quality of thinking by the quality of
their questions and it always stands out
if somebody asks you a question that's
on point or breaks the frame of how
you're thinking about things um that
person always stands out in a meeting
even though they didn't deliver some
like you know very boastful confident
conclusion and so you know an example of
this would be you're in a meeting and
it's kind of a messy
it looks like you know options A and B
both suck um instead of just saying no
we need to do a or no we need to do B
somebody who asks a different question
that's like you know um what would an
easy solution look like here right hey
what's the simple thing we're missing
right I'm just going to ask this out
loud let's see if there's see if there's
an answer because if there is that might
be quite valuable to us right now or um
you know we've been saying this thing uh
just want to say this out loud is that
true do we have the data to support that
like somebody who's questioning
assumptions or breaking frames with
their questions or that says you know
we're trying to solve this problem feels
like we're solving it from scratch we're
not the only ones who have this problem
how do other people solve this or how
have we solved this in the past what's
worked for us and anybody who's asking
questions like that that are going to
cut to the answer faster you stand out
that's a that's a different way of
showing confidence versus just saying me
me me I I have the
answer dude I I the one question that I
love that all my employees hate is
they'll give this
like 12 month plan or something I'm like
yeah how do we do this in like four
weeks right that question question some
of the best people they they frame that
question nicely they say this this guy
floran I used to work with he would
always say this he'd be like I'm gonna
say something you could beat me up if
you think this is a terrible idea uh you
know you feel free to beat me up but I
just want to say it and then he'll say
the thing and it's such a disarming way
of bringing up an idea that might be
countered to way the the flow is going
or whatever because you're always like
oh FL we're not you we're not don't
worry we're not going to beat you up
about this idea but he would say that
right or
um you know this other guy Dan he would
he would do this thing he's now the CEO
of twitch he would do this thing in
meetings where he'd say you know he'd
slow everybody down he'd be like you
know it's one thing we could say is a b
and c he'd like lay out an argument real
quick he's like it's one thing to say
this it's another thing if we were gonna
say you know
DF and he would just like frame it so
slowly for everybody cuz usually it's
the person who can kind of like
synthesize the arguments like what I'm
hearing you're saying is a and c I just
want to make sure that it's is it ab and
c and not actually de andf and the
person who would bring that Clarity to
the meeting was always like the
essential person right they're the
person who everybody thinks that they're
on the way out because they actually
help you you know figure out the
solution where it felt like everybody
was just talking in circles what uh you
want to do one or two or three more uh
yeah okay here's an easy one let's say
you're inside of a company today but you
want to go start a company someday you
need to start creating your own version
of the Midas list which is who are the
five most interesting people inside this
company the people that you would want
to recruit later on what I did was I I
just I said at the beginning I said
while I'm here at this job here's what I
want out of this by the time I leave
these doors I want to have the following
I said and I wrote down a list one of
them was like I want to learn one or two
things about leading a company that I
don't know today because these people
have managed bigger teams and it better
than I I'm sure that that I do it so I
want to at least have one or two key
things that I can take away as a manager
number two I want to have the respect of
the CEO I want him to be able to say
dude if you leave here and you tell me
you're gonna go start a company I want
him to uh want to write the first check
I think that would just be a a signal
that I did well when I was here would
EMT do that for you uh yeah he actually
slacked me one time he was like Hey I
out of the blue he's he basically
slacked me that exact same thing he was
like uh I wish we going I wish we'd be
able to keep you forever I don't think
that's going to happen uh you know if
you ever do decide to do something I'd
love to you know you know I'd love to
back you in that and I was like oh man
what a compliment thank you that's
actually I showed him actually I was
like that was on my list of things I
said I wanted out of this experience so
that's a cool full circle moment um the
third one is you want I I said I want to
walk out of here with five people five
more people in my talent rod decks that
I could reach out to if I ever needed to
hire and um and that's what I did I was
like oh this girl in data science
massively underrated like she's the real
one who delivers the work she's kind of
Junior here but man she would be
somebody I would poach right away or
this guy over here on the sales team God
that guy was smooth um if I ever have a
thing for sales I know who to who to
contact and actually right now with one
of our new companies um I'm trying to
fill a role and those are the people I
went to first to be like hey I have no
idea if you're available but I made this
list before of who are the five people I
would love to work with someday and you
were on it and hey that day is here uh
you know what what are you up to now and
let's let's chat and so that's I think
another good thing if you ever want to
start a company like just pay attention
to who are the hitters here because your
talent roled is what kind of becomes a
limiting factor as you try to build new
companies right like I'm sure you have
people that you know you'd love to speed
dial and bring on board to a new thing
and I think you did this with Hampton
right like I notic there's some people
there that were at the hustle because
that's the experience you had yeah I
think that you actually asked was it you
who said something like a really good
question ask yourself is if you're
starting your like let's say your
thing's only going okay if you were if
you were starting it again would you
would you'd have to ask yourself would I
hire the same people and do it the same
way and for many cases you say no I
would change this this and this and then
your advice to them was like well just
do that right now do that yeah
yeah but the but the other answer is
okay well when you do it again now you
have your list I think uh you know in
the mafia they use the phrase and then
succession kind of stole the phrase
where they say like oh he's a serious
person and a serious person means you
call them hitters but in the mafia and
the mob like I read all these books on
it and they say uh oh he's serious he's
serious yeah that guy's serious and so
or they'll say he's not a serious person
you don't want to mess with that person
so you want to find serious people I
have two other little ones uh real fast
ones one is find a paper cut problem so
I've noticed that a lot of people who do
well in companies they do this in the
first two weeks when they join they find
something that's just been an annoyance
that nobody's ever fixed or nobody's got
to um because it's not that important
it's never the most important thing and
they just go clean that up voluntarily I
call this the paper problem like what's
the thing that's just been given to us
paper cuts it's kind of annoying but
you're not bleeding out you're not dying
you don't have to go to the hospital and
if somebody fixed it you'd be like dude
thank you for doing that like you know
it would actually stand out a lot um I
know several people that did this they
they go to a company and they
immediately identify like oh here's some
annoyance that two people have
referenced I bet this annoys everybody
and actually I think if I just spent one
Saturday working on this I could fix it
and they did that and it just like boost
their stock so much when I was in
seventh grade I had a job at a bakery
and I would like clean the floors and
wash dishes and there was a corner or
there was a shelf where we'd have to
like put these dyed dishes and the Shelf
was broken and we hired another janitor
to work with me and I remember like I
had worked there for like eight months
and this shelf was always broken
it was a pain in the ass and like within
the first week this guy fixed that shelf
and I immediately thought that's the way
to do things you right exactly did it
right and by the way you get rewarded
for doing the things you didn't have to
do right like
if you just do your job that's called
your job you do not get like extra
recognition or reward or or any kind of
bonus points for doing your job so you
by definition you have to find something
that is beyond your job or doing your
job beyond what was asked uh if you
really want to get this to stand out
it's a very simple obvious principle but
take that and make it actionable by like
go look for it right as soon as you
start looking for it you'll see it right
it's it's it's a thing that the guy
who's been there for eight months has
been ignoring he's become he's just
accepted it it's become a blind spot for
them but for a new person if you're
noticing you'll see it right away and
you just go fix that thing and you get
so much yeah this guy's head janitor now
I mean it worked out
out but honestly if you're gonna be a
janitor be the head janitor like be the
best janor be the best goddamn janitor
anybody's ever seen I got one practical
one and then one fun one practical one
is the other problem you want to find is
the A+ problem at any given time in any
company there is the A Plus problem it
is the thing that the PE that's keeping
you know the the exec team up at night
they're worried about it what I did was
I just found the A+ problem and I would
only work on that I would just work on
that you know I would do my my main job
kind of like you know 70% is good or 50%
is good or sometimes 0% is good I would
just put it on pause because honestly it
didn't even matter relative to the A+
problem and uh you know I took a little
more risk than most people because I
didn't care if I ever got fired like it
was you know thank you please fire me
invest my shares that would be a dream
but by the way we had a friend who uh is
at a company and he goes there was
layoffs this week at our company and
sadly I was not
impacted
exactly um so finally a probably work on
it I remember um I think I've told this
story before um I was at a company and
basically a competitor was like
attacking them and like what was you
know stealing their top customer
basically and I figured well that's
probably the A+ problem probably
thinking everybody's thinking about and
so I just did some analysis did wrote up
a two-page doc and I sent it to the CEO
I was like hey you know I have no idea
who's working on this but you know I was
curious so I dug in and here's what I
found and immediately got like text
inted into a group chat like hey Sean's
in on this now and I think that that's
that's really what you want right is you
want to be working on the interesting
things because that's what the highest
caliber people are doing it's where the
highest impact is you might as well you
have only have so many hours in the day
might as well work on the higher impact
stuff with the most interesting High
Caliber people that's how you get better
um what's your last fun one the last fun
one is you got to create a brand for
yourself so like you have a little story
right there's all these moments inside
companies where it's like you do
introductions or uh you're at some team
offsite and uh you know you have two
choices you're either going to blend in
or you're going to stand out the best
way to stand out is to be yourself but
the the way to be yourself is to just
remove the filter and so what was your
brand so I think there's been a couple
yeah like when I was at Monkey Inferno
just to give you a sense of this right
I'm 24 years old I'm the youngest person
in the company I'm the newest hire in
the company and six months later I got
named CEO Prodigy that's pretty good
pretty good right and the way to do that
is you actually you know you make an
impact but you also got to build some
sort of brand for yourself and so mine
was I was going to be sort of like um
the action like basically just like take
Massive Action on everything so whatever
the thing was I would be like all right
cool I'm going to take action on it a
immediately B I'm going to do the
that nobody else wants to do like I'm
going to go further oh we got to do this
or we don't know if people will like
this who cool give me the Prototype I'm
going to go talk to some people I would
go to the mall and I would talk to
people and I get feedback and i' come
back with like written feedback it was
just a that nobody else really
wanted to do and it just built this
thing like I'm going to consistently
take action I'm G have a higher bias for
action than anybody else and I would
talk about that I'd be like yeah like I
don't really know uh you know I remember
this one guy did this intro and he said
this thing this guy stood up and he
goes I don't know anything about art or
politics I don't know he goes I don't
know anything about art I don't know
anything about politics hell I don't
even know where the remote is in my
house the remote for the TV is in my
house but the one thing I know is how to
structure deals and today I'm going to
tell you about how to structure deals
and I was like wow what an intro what a
what a fantastic intro it like always
stood out to me and I thought you know
what as much as your brand is going to
be that you're good at X Y and Z you
could say how bad you are or how little
you know about you know these other
three things and just be honest about it
and almost poke fun at yourself so I
would tell people like look I have the
least experience of anybody in this room
that's obvious I have never worked on
any of this stuff before I don't know
how to code I don't know how to design
but I'm gonna make myself useful the way
the way I'm going to do that is it seems
like what you guys need is help actually
getting your product into people's hands
and getting feedback quickly and
actually iterating from there so I'm GNA
go crazy on that all right what you guys
are going to get in the next six weeks
is me going crazy on that sound good and
they're like they're like great it's
like Warren Buffett says look for
partners who have an high IQ who are
ethical and have a lot of energy and I I
I did the same thing where I was like
well I actually don't know if I'm high
IQ two out of three a bad yeah yeah I
don't know I definitely am ethical and I
and I have a ton of energy so my
wheels are spinning fast if you guys
just want to put me in the right
direction I'll go ahead and the car will
run and it'll run quickly and I'll get
you what you need I had the exact same
brand as you and when we got acquired I
just was like Hey I'm a startup guy
inside this big company I'm the I'm I'm
a startup guy I've only ever worked in
startups I don't know anything about a
big company honestly I'm going to
probably make some mistakes that are
things that are obvious that you should
do in a big company but the thing I hope
hope to bring to the table is I'm just
going to keep working the way I know how
as an entrepreneur I'm just going to
just do that here and uh you guys tell
me what parts of that are working for
you guys or what are not right that's
part of the brand but the other part is
like stand out a little bit I remember
sitting in an offsite is like oh um how
about everybody just share you know how
things are going and it was like person
one said this like boring thing about
like you know they just immediately went
into like work mod right like you know
they were like you know here's what I'm
doing here's the problem I'm having
here's what I'm doing here's the problem
I'm having here I have this employee
who's doing this and every was just kind
of bitching and moaning and telling a
very Bland story and I just decided when
it's going to come my term I don't know
what's gonna come out of my mouth but
it's not gonna be that and so I just
told a story that was more funny it was
poking fun of myself about something
that I had done recently and a mistake
that I had made so instead of blaming my
team or my whatever I just told her I
was like you know here's where my head's
at because all you they weren't saying
like give us a team update they were
just saying like you know let's all be
present just share what's on our mind
how you're feeling right now and so I
did that and that stood out at the break
everybody was like dude I love that
story um and you know the the lesson
there is really like take a bit of a
risk and don't take yourself too
seriously inside companies because I
think there's a tendency to try to
button up and blend in and uh I would
say that's not what the best people do I
don't think that's what I don't think
that's how the best people act we have
this guy at Hampton named Doug and Doug
is a very stereotypical engineer so he's
very black and white and because of that
he's done a very good job of just being
honest constantly and so if someone's
trying to me I'll just be like
uh what's Doug think Doug what do you
think and he'll just be like that's
stupid or he won't say that way he'll be
like I don't think that's the right way
I think this is the right way and for
these reasons or he'll be like uh I
don't like I don't exactly understand
like branding but I think that a lot of
people like this this this and this and
they like it for these reasons therefore
that way is or is not the right way and
it's just what it's Doug I just always
want to know what's Doug think about
this he's very analytical and he's very
honest and he doesn't because he's you
know like a normal engineer he doesn't
exactly understand what's hurting my
feelings or what isn't hurting my
feelings and I love that about him I
love that i' always want Doug in my life
people who just don't me and
they'll say something like that's stupid
that's not stupid and I appreciate that
that's his brand so th those are our
tips how to become I don't know a
superstar inside of a company how to
stand out how to make a name for inside
of a company and if you're uh if you're
if you're listening on on iTunes or uh
Spotify go to the YouTube and a
subscribe because we're about to cross
400,000 and B comment other questions
that you have for the new segment
questionable advice if we get any good
questions we'll do it I like how you
said the YouTube that's how my dad says
it too that's cool go to the
YouTube yeah when I look at when I hold
my phone to take a picture I use two
hands as
well yesterday I go
I'm like posting ay trying to post a Tik
Tok a day and I love doing it I saw what
you said yeah that was great every time
I post a Tik Tok I feel like I ate I
like reverse my age by one month I'm
just getting younger just by TiK ToK by
Tik Tok if you want to be young you do
as the young people do you gota like and
you're G you're squinting your eyes
you're gonna hold your phone with two
hands and you're gonna like look down on
it that's how it feels right now turn
the damn thing
off all right that's the
pod
[Music]